[Musique]
paris saclay tdp sa rentrée bienvenue
ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle saison
lakovic 19 a bouleversé notre quotidien
mais l'université paris saclay résiste
et se classe même au 14e rang du
prestigieux classement des universités
de shanghai une première remarquée le
campus vous le savez ces trois
universités
quatre grandes écoles une dernière
arrivée le ms l'école normale supérieure
nous avons rencontré son président
pierre paul zalio télécom paris c'est
aussi partie des petits nouveaux c'est
une grande école d'ingénieurs son
directeur nicolas glady nous a reçu dans
son tout nouveau bâtiment entretien à
suivre paris saclay vous propose aussi
un site internet pour manger local
enfin je vous propose une visite
artistique alors vous allez découvrir
des oeuvres d'hier mais aussi des
oeuvres d'aujourd'hui vous verrez ce
reportage dans quelques minutes et enfin
votre agenda et bien c'est à la fin de
cette émission
[Musique]
nous voici donc à télécom paris
prestigieuse école d'ingénieurs une
école qui fait sa première vraie rentrée
palaisienne il ya 3000 élèves alors à
cause de la qu'ovide et effectivement
ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux mais le
directeur de cet établissement est avec
nous bonjour nicolas glady bonjour merci
d'être avec nous donc une rentrée un peu
compliqué à cause de la covit vous étiez
prêts alors on a commencé à travailler
sur cette question là en fait dès mai
avant la rentrée puisque on a établi un
groupe de travail spécifique sur la
question de la rentrée sous pandémie est
donc encore on a dans un premier temps
fait avec ce groupe de travail établi
toutes les modalités pédagogiques qu'on
pouvait envisager succo vide dans un
premier temps et puis on l'a fait
remonter sur base de ce travail
préliminaire les attentes à la fois des
étudiants et des enseignants-chercheurs
et donc une fois qu'on avait toutes ces
informations on a pu établir un planning
de rentrée qu'on avait donc établi dans
et quelques semaines qui ont précédé
septembre qu'on a fait bien sûr aussi
valider auprès des différentes instances
le chsct etc
pour avoir la rentrée qu'on a
aujourd'hui la chance qu'on a eu aussi
c'est qu'on a un tout nouveau bâtiment
on en parlera certainement et donc avec
aussi des espaces qui se prête à de
l'espace justement entre les étudiants
puisque c'est que c'est important et les
modalités pédagogiques en digital avec
des caméras des micros qui fonctionne
bien des écrans qui font retour des gens
qui pouvaient être à distance qui nous a
permis en fait d'avoir très rapidement
et aussi avec un peu de travail il faut
le dire la possibilité d'avoir des
centres d enseignement hybride
alors pour ceux qui ont la chance d'être
ici dans ce bâtiment c'est vous là vous
l'avez dit c'est un bâtiment tout neuf
qui a été primé les architectes ont été
primés c'est un peu un lieu presque
monacale c'est ça c'est comment rentrer
à pied comme paris ont ont fait une
profession de foi on alors moi j'aime
beaucoup effectivement nous inscrire
dans la tradition académique à la
tradition académique vient effectivement
du monde ecclésiastique y en a on a une
histoire commune sur tout un tas de
dimensions alors effectivement je ne
dirais pas qu'elle transfère chercheurs
c'est un sacerdoce
mais quand même c'est certainement il
faut avoir une fois dans la vérité et sa
recherche qui est très très forte que
moi j'aime beaucoup effectivement se
rappelle à l'histoire de nos
établissements et des établissement
centenaire est la plupart des écoles de
l'institut polytechnique de paris ont
d'ailleurs parmi les écoles membre d'un
institut polytechnique de paris la plus
vieille école d'ingénieur avec les stars
donc effectivement s'inscrit dans une
tradition longue
effectivement le cabinet d'architectes
grafton qui a conçu ce bâtiment s'est
imprégné s'est inspiré de l'histoire
alors monacale 2
de ce genre d'établissement merci
beaucoup a dit d'avoir accueilli dans ce
magnifique bâtiment tout neuf et pour
cette première vraie rentrée parisienne
merci merci à vous
[Musique]
c'est une institution une de plus qui
s'installe sur votre territoire le ls
l'école normale supérieure fait sa
rentrée dans ce bâtiment flambant neuf
signée renzo piano et c'est son
président qui nous accueillent merci
beaucoup
bonjour pierre paul l'allier bonjour
merci encore une fois je sais que je ne
rentrais un petit peu compliqué on
imagine déjà il faut s'emparer de ce
nouveau bâtiment qui est magnifique mais
il ya aussi lakovic 19 alors comment
s'est passé votre rentrée bon la rentrée
s'est passée un petit peu dans
l'attitude de lakovic 19 on va pas se
voiler la face
bon en même temps il y avait là
paradoxalement la joie de découvrir ce
bâtiment je n'ai pas peur de dire ça
parce que ce qu'il fera appel et les
collègues autant que les élèves et les
étudiants qui rentrait c'était quand
même les qualités du bâtiment là le
confort immédiat qui pouvait donner donc
ça veut c'est venu un peu contrebalancé
cette cette atmosphère voilà après la
rentrée s'est relativement bien passée
malgré tout dans la mesure où on avait
anticipé beaucoup des difficultés que
peut causer la copie de 19 sur une
rentrée en prévoyant un type
d'organisation des cours un type de
rentrée qui était compatible avec les
mesures de distanciation
oui c'est à dire présentiel et aussi dit
enfin digital on regarde numérique pour
partie présentiel pour partie et distant
ciel avec une attention sur les demies
jauge dans les salles des dispositifs de
sécurisation
accentuer le gel prévu l'ensemble de
l'entrée de tous les ans filles de
toutes les salles donc tous de tous les
bâtiments
donc je pense qu'on a pu donner aux
étudiants
le sentiment que la rentrée était bien
maîtrisée bien que ce soit dans un
contexte difficile
un mode sept bâtiments c'est un peu le
miroir l'image de le n est ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle a été dit nous alors ce
qu'elle est et puisqu'elle veut être est
ce qu'elle va continuer à vouloir être
parce que ce set atrium là dans lequel
on se trouve au fond et c'est une sorte
de rue intérieure qui fait à peu près
170 m de long et toutes les entités de
l'école ou presque pas tout à fait tout
mais presque toutes les entités de
l'école donne sur cette atrium aussi
bien en enseignement en recherche donc
il ya deux aspects qui sont que ce
bâtiment illustré que c'est atrium
illustre c'est le fait que toute
l'équipe discipline de la connaissance
sont à proximité les unes des autres et
peuvent se voir la biologie va voir les
mathématiques va voir l'informatique va
voir la chimie il va voir la physique va
voir les sciences pour l'ingénieur dans
leur diversité donc lie le design donc
là on a toutes les disciplines qui se
voit et en même temps vous allez voir
dans ces couloirs dans cette atrium des
salles de cours des salles de recherche
qui sont des sales vraiment des
laboratoires du cnrs par exemple qui
sont imbriqués les uns dans les autres
pour ça que c'est votre première entrée
sur le plateau
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
cette première rentrée pour le n est ce
qu'on peut souhaiter collectivement
enfin à l'école et à ses partenaires
mais assez de poursuivre la route qu'ils
ont commencé ensemble on a on a ce
classement
on a maintenant une université qui a un
statut expérimental dans lesquelles les
différentes écoles différentes écoles
sont entrés avec un partenariat qu'ils
organisent donc il faut que ce chemin
continue il faut qu'il continue dans le
même état d'esprit positif que qui a été
celui qui l'a marqué depuis
depuis quelques années merci beaucoup
pierre-paul zaio merci de nous avoir
accueillis mais je vous en prie
[Musique]
le plateau de paris saclay c'est un
couvert aux portes de paris des terrains
agricoles des fermes et donc la chance
de pouvoir manger local
mais encore faut-il connaître les
adresses le pea ps a mis en place un
site pour pouvoir manger local c'est
moins cher cet écolo c'est délicieux
alors sans plus attendre découvrez cette
nouvelle plateforme
le pea paris saclay porte une initiative
de plateforme de valorisation des
exploitations agricoles qui s'appelle
donc manger local à paris saclay et qui
a pour objectif en fait de mettre en
lien les agriculteurs les points de
vente et les consommateurs du territoire
que sont à la fois les habitants les
salariés et également les étudiants du
territoire le site
manger local à paris saclay vise
également donc à créer des liens entre
les espaces urbains et les espaces
agricoles du territoire au travers de la
découverte de l'agriculture du plateau
est également des lieux de consommation
de ces produits agricoles
cette plateforme manger local à paris
saclay est notamment financée par le
ministère de la transition écologique au
travers du dispositif territoire à
énergie positive pour la croissance
verte
on a la chance sur le plateau de saclay
et autour d'avoir une vingtaine de
fermes qui produisent encore une
diversité de produits locaux on a du
pain des fruits des légumes des produits
laitiers et une partie des terres
agricoles sont protégés par la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière l'idée de ce site internet
c'est de pouvoir faire profiter à tout
le monde de ces délicieux produits
locaux qu'on a sur le territoire
l'objectif du site c'est de rendre
facile la consommation locale et de vous
donner toutes les infos pratiques pour
accéder aux produits locaux savoir où
ils sont produits dans quelle ferme
qu'est ce qui est produit sur le
territoire et aussi où est ce que vous
pouvez les trouver
donc ce sera simple de trouver les
différents points de vente et les
différents modes d'achats de produits
locaux sur ce site
l'idée du site c'est aussi de mieux
faire comprendre les métiers des
agriculteurs du plateau de saclay et de
vous plonger dans l'univers agricole du
territoire avec notamment des belles
vidéos des belles photos et des
citations des agriculteurs des
explications sur leur travail au
quotidien
bonjour donc bienvenu on garde manger
est la ferme de romainville le conte
marie jonas on a décidé de diversifier
l'activité de la ferme et d'ouvrir une
boutique ici en rénovant une belle
grange est donc de proposer en fait que
des produits fermiers en circuit court
qui dit circuits courts c'est vraiment
du direct producteur et produits fermés
parce que tout est transformé donc chez
les agriculteurs il ya vraiment pas de
pas d'intermédiaire et l'idée c'était de
proposer déjà nos produits à nous donc
nous on a de la farine de la sphère de
lui les colzas des lentilles vertes et
du miel et de travailler en direct avec
d'autres producteurs pour les fruits et
légumes la viande le fromage la
charcuterie enfin voilà plein de bonnes
choses pour en fait remplir un panier
hebdomadaire
[Musique]
voilà pour les nourritures terrestres
mais votre territoire c'est aussi tout
un patrimoine culturel des oeuvres
collectionnés depuis plus de 40 ans par
l'université paris saclay mais aussi des
créations contemporaines
le trait tarte se développe vous avez
certainement admirer ses fresques un peu
partout sur le territoire
visite guidée avec patrice godart
responsable de la valorisation de ce
patrimoine culturel
[Musique]
dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine
j'ai donc organisé une visite des
oeuvres du campus du campus vallée à
orsay concernant aussi bien des
sculptures que des toiles qui
appartiennent ou un fort sens artistique
acquis depuis maintenant les années 60
et 70 par l'université paris sud
aujourd'hui l'université paris saclay
bien évidemment et donc j'étais
accompagné pour ce faire par un
professeur honoraire de géologie qui
expliquait la nature des matériaux
utilisés pour la conception des
sculptures et puis par un street artiste
parce que cette visite aussi concerner
le street art que nous développons de
manière assidue sur le campus vallée à
savoir nous avons maintenant huit
oeuvres qui sont relatives au street art
est donc cette personne a pu nous
expliquer aussi la technique empruntée
pour réaliser ses oeuvres monumentales
dans le cadre du 1 % artistique de
nouveaux bâtiments voit le jour
ce qui concerne l'université paris
saclay et donc il est intéressant
d'essayer de développer la création
d'oeuvres du 1 portion artistique dans
ce cadre très précis
il ya également donc un grand patrimoine
architectural à l'université paris
saclay et donc je m'intéresse essayé à
l'avenir qu'un certain nombre de ses
bâtiments puisse acquérir le label
architecture contemporaine remarquable
qui est l'ancien label patrimoine du
xxème siècle ce label valoriserait un
certain nombre de bâtiments et donc un
travail va être effectué dans ce sens
également ce travail de préservation du
patrimoine et de valorisation de ce même
patrimoine implique une collaboration de
l'ensemble des établissements qui
composent l'université paris saclay et
donc toutes les bonnes volontés seront
les bienvenues dans l'intérêt est
évidemment de la culture dans l'intérêt
des étudiants qui sont les premiers
usagers de cette culture
et puis bien sûr dans l'intérêt de notre
belle université à paris saclay qui a
atteint maintenant le 14e rang au
classement de shanghaï et donc il est
nécessaire que sur le plan culturel et
bien les choses se développent dans cet
esprit et dans ce seront nouveau établi
pour pour l'université paris saclay
et maintenant notre agenda
la fête de la science c'est tout le mois
d'octobre avec plus d'une soixantaine de
rendez vous qui vous attendent dans
quinze communes de l'agglomération paris
saclay n'oublions pas non plus les
jeudis de la recherche le grand public
est invité à se rendre au coeur des
laboratoires de la faculté des sciences
d'orsay ou de polytechnique voire du
cnrs
prochain rendez vous le jeudi 5 novembre
avec une recherche au service de la
protection biologique du maïs
rencontre avec laure kaizer arnaud c'est
au laboratoire évolution génome
comportement et écologie ou campus cnrs
s'est agi sur yvette beaucoup de rendez
vous scientifique mais si vous aimez la
culture ne serait pas déçu avec une
grande exposition d'art urbain à
versailles l'art du trompe-l'oeil
s'expose en ville c'est à l'espace
richaud et c'est jusqu'au 29 novembre
vous pouvez aussi découvrir essais
photographiques de dan rama ans et au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est gratuit l'entrée libre donc et
c'est jusqu'au 19 décembre 2020 est
resté au théâtre de saint quentin pour
voir de la danse contemporaine avec
abaca c'est la dernière création de
béatrice massin c'est du 3 au 7 novembre
laissez vous tenter par cette création
baroque
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis pour rester
informé n'oubliez pas notre site pap.fr
d'ici là respecter les gestes barrières
et surtout surtout prenez soin de vous
et de vos proches à très vite
[Musique]